kevin i think is even more famous and he
has 2.5 or 3 million subscribers he
recently did a video and it was called
here's my entire 50 million dollar
portfolio at age 29. so i and i noticed
that he had done one of these i'm
clicking
okay double click full screen headphones
on
and i noticed that he did another one of
these like nine months ago or 13 months
ago something like around a year ago and
his net worth then was only 25 and i was
like what is going on this guy is nuts
and so he's basically this guy meet
kevin i don't know his full name he um
it makes like three to four videos a day
and he is talking about like which
stocks he's buying uh which um
types of houses he's buying for
investment properties and he shows his
entire portfolio and at the end he goes
now here's proof and he logs in to all
of his accounts and you can see all of
it screen share yes which is
amazing for many reasons one
he's only 29 and he's a youtuber with 50
million dollars
how was he how did he how did he get
that money so he's just off of his
youtube or he had some other business
that he
started with at age 19 i believe he
started as just a real estate agent so
just a normal guy okay and he made a
little bit of money like a hundred grand
a year took that hundred grand a year
and bought some properties and then
started a youtube channel in 2010 or
2011 and he just started documenting
about his real estate investing slowly
that started making additional income
using that income he bought even more
properties eventually he had like a
course and things like that where he was
making like one or two million dollars a
year so a significant amount of sum
or a significant sum
then he took that money and he started
investing it and started talking about
what he was investing and you could see
this entire growth over the last five
years of his portfolio and how it's
grown of course it helps that a he's got
now a significant stream of like four
million dollars a year i would imagine
and we're in the best bull market of all
time
and so
it kind of works but that's how he's
done it and interestingly this guy kevin
uh when gavin newsom was being recalled
kevin ran for office and there's this
republican named larry elder who got
second behind gavin newsom kevin was
third with something like hundreds of
thousands of votes
and so it's this kid's amazing and so
that's surprising i feel like a youtuber
who's got a big following should crush
any politician he doesn't have that big
a following he only has 2.5 or 3 million
it's not significant and it has to be a
california above 18 voter so it's not
like it's not significant but my point
being with a lot of these youtubers is
this video was nutty and graham stefan
did the exact same thing he goes here's
my prediction
mr beast or a mr beast type person will
run for president and will surprise
people with the type of following they
get because oh absolutely whether you
want to be president or not you could
you know i think the original trump
playbook was i'm gonna just throw my hat
in the ring i'm gonna get tons of
attention and press i'm gonna build my
brand off the
the massive amount of attention that
goes into elections and i'll be the the
kind of curveball story that everybody
wants to cover everybody's got an
opinion on
like kanye kanye did it or whatever he
threw his name in you're gonna see the
wild wild west of people trying to put
their name in the hat for running for
office or running for these kind of like
positions that will sound
you know how could a how could a 21 year
old youtuber be doing this and they're
going to get a little momentum and then
that's going to create a press cycle
that's going to create more momentum i
don't think they'll actually win i don't
think they even want to win but it would
just be a smart move for the dog-eat-dog
world of youtube trying to get views
yeah
and and but here's back to the original
point of getting views
what is exhausting life that you have to
go and and i'm thankful that mr beast
does what he does i'm thankful that this
kevin guy and graham are crazy enough to
log in and show me their that is so cool
they are nuts that is nuts